good afternoon I am very pleased and
honored to welcome to our University
great personality a man that has worked
for more than a quarter of a century for
the cause of peace and security in a
world dr. Hans Blix has been one of the
bravest and most judicious voices of our
time on the dangers posed to humanity by
weapons of mass destruction dr. Blake's
you may know has had a very brilliant
career in academia then he went to serve
his country in Sweden's government and
then he went to serve the international
community in various capacities after
having served as minister of foreign
affairs of Sweden in the late 1970s he
became the director general of the
International Atomic Energy Agency a
post that he hell for 16 years and he is
remembered as a very effective and brave
director general not only he was
technically very capable but unlike some
versions in this country he was by no
means a wimp it was a tough man at that
position then he retired but in year two
thousand he was asked by
secretary-general kofi annan to retire
from retirement and he became the UN
weapons inspector little did he know
that a few months or years later
he will be under tremendous pressure to
address the very simple issue of Iraq
and we all know how his life was between
november of 2002 and march up 2003 when
he and his people conducted solvent in
like 400 the inspections in three
hundred sites 700 inspections in iraq
and i remember that in a report he gave
to the Security Council in February up
2003 just one month before the military
intervention dr. Bleek's stated very
clearly that he had not found any
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq and
now we know that he was right and others
were wrong we are very fortunate to have
a testimony of dr. Blake's experience in
that at that time he wrote this very
fine book disarming Iraq which has now
been a claim in Europe and also in the
United States but you know he never
tires and as he was writing this book he
was he had already accepted to share a
commission a commission on weapons of
mass destruction and he gathered this
incredible group of people from several
countries experts to produce and they
produce this report weapons of terror
free in the world of nuclear biological
and chemical arms i think the report was
published only vision in june first of
this year this is something that i
strongly recommend it's a star Denari
reading so here we are honored by his
presence he has been kind enough to
accept
our invitation and just helped me to
help to receive with gratitude and
admiration dr. hands links
thank you very much dr. sevillio and
professor some fellow students I'm very
pleased to be at the University and I
think that one of the most important
lessons that we can learn is to maintain
critical thinking or what we see or what
we read and even critical thinking of
what we have thought and written
ourselves looking back on it now as
someone said to me that he looked he
admired those were searching for truth
and looked with a little concern upon
those who have the truth I think that's
a good starting point judging by the
political discourse the main threat to
world security today is the possible
development and possession of weapons of
mass destruction nuclear biological and
chemical in some states of concern they
used to be called rogue states but
nowadays the more polite expression in
the states of concern but what they mean
is really still Iran and North Korea or
by terrorist groups one might get the
impression that the some 27,000 nuclear
weapons which are deemed to exist in
eight states post few problems and that
we need not worry about them even though
many of them are on hair-trigger alert
the international commission of weapons
of mass destruction which I chaired and
which presented his report in june of
this year weapons of terror how to free
the world from chemical biological and
nuclear weapons recognizes that weapons
of mass destruction especially in
nuclear weapons may be particularly
dangerous in some hands but it sees them
as a threat in who's ever hands they are
the commission points out that there is
not only stagnation in disarmament and
arms control since the end of the Cold
War but even science / renewed arms race
involving new types of nuclear weapons
countermeasures to the missile shield
and the possible deployment of weapons
in space it urges governments and public
opinion to wake up
to the risk of this race and to revive
arms control and disarmament which
paradoxically were more fruitful efforts
during the Cold War world military
expenses are not going down last year
they are estimated to be about one
trillion dollars for the world a little
less than half of that falling on the
United States in 2005 the u.s. spent
three point seven percent of its gdp on
defense while Europe's NATO members were
spending about 1.9 percent of their gdp
it is true that we do not at the present
time see any risk of major powers using
armed force against each other world
security is not threatened by a nuclear
dual which could result in the mutually
assured destruction of major powers and
the rest of us probably be wiped off as
collateral damage today's relations
between the great powers are not exactly
relaxed but they're also not tense there
may are no there are no territorial or
significant ideological controversies
between them all pursue the market
economy or various shades and shapes and
their they're all dent on pragmatism
European countries no longer see Russia
as a military threat in many states in
Europe our reorienting their armed
forces from defense of their own
territory to the use in international
peacekeeping for peace enforcing
operations and NATO is looking for tasks
outside Europe in my own country we have
conscription but they give preference to
those who are ready and declare that
they are willing to serve in
peacekeeping operations a year ago the
under secular peacekeeping at the United
Nations noted that there were less wars
and they used to be and that there were
about 25 armed conflicts in the world
last year down from more than 50 during
the early 1990s and that most armed
conflicts in the world today are civil
wars and that the number of people
killed in battle in the world is at the
present time a hunt at a hundred year
low this was last year and it doesn't
change very much
here so this statistics sound pretty
hopeful and yet the national security
strategy published earlier this year
begins were the words words America is
at war and in the past year we have
heard President Bush say that 911 was
the Pearl Harbor of the third world war
well that is clearly not at peace in
examining world security we can also not
ignore that the US and some allied
States actually went to war in Iraq in
2003 and that the political
justification given was primarily the
contention that Iraq retained weapons of
mass destruction in violation of
Security Council resolutions while there
were many other motives for the action
as you all know it is unlikely that any
of these are motives an argument would
had persuaded the US Congress or the UK
Parliament to authorize armed action it
shows the weight of the issue of weapons
of mass destruction and in particular
that of nuclear weapons as we know the
evidence of the Iraqi weapons of mass
destruction was 14 and the reports of
Inuvik which I chair and the IAEA where
Mohamed ElBaradei have succeeded me
these reports were ignored by the
state's launching the war on Logic had
carried out some 700 inspections at 500
different sites dozens of them actually
proposed by the intelligence services of
the US and UK and other countries and we
had reported no fines or weapons of mass
destruction we had also not said that
there are no weapons mass destruction we
have you been criticized for that and
said you could have spoken up you should
have said that there were no weapons of
mass destruction but then we had not
kept the objective attitude you cannot
never absolutely be sure that there's
nothing hidden somewhere so you can say
that we have studied we have examined
inspected diligently and after such a
such a thing we have not found anything
that's not exactly the same thing but
it's more truthful more scientific than
the other way quite to the contrary the
unmarked and the IAEA had publicly
expressed doubts about some of the
evidence that had been presented and in
private talks as you will see if in my
book I had said to come
rice that we were not impressed with
intelligence and she answered me on that
occasion that mr. Blix is not the
intelligence that is being tested is
Iraq that's being tested and I said to
premise a blare over the telephone also
that wouldn't be paradoxical if you
invaded Iraq with hundreds of thousands
and then and found nothing he said no no
don't worry even the Egyptian
intelligence has the same view as we do
so they seem to be convinced the police
of the majority of the Security Council
that inspections should be continued
were ignored and the war was launched
without any authorization of the council
it was launched indeed in the full
awareness that the council would refuse
an authorization the war in Iraq in 2003
was not justified as was the war in 1991
that was justified by the need to
counter an armed attack in 1991 Iraq had
attacked and occupied QIT nor could the
war in 2003 be justified by an
allegation that an armed attack was
imminent it was said rather to be an
action to uphold the UN Security Council
resolutions which advantage were
violated by Iraq even though the council
majority would not accept such an action
so the authority the council was upheld
as it were against its will while the US
did not officially argue that the war
was justified as a pre-emptive action
against the Iraq in a rocky threat of
attack there is no doubt that this view
was held a US national security strategy
had been published as you might remember
in September 2002 in a stand flatly
stated that a limitation of the right
unilaterally to use armed force in
self-defense to cases where armed
attacks were occurring or were imminent
would be insufficient in the era of
missiles and terrorists the limitations
which were thus rejected were precisely
the UN Charter ones which are found in
article 51 of the Charter the position
in 2002 was confirmed in the national
security strategy or 2006 this year and
statements that in the case of Iran all
options are on the tape
frequently heard they confirm that the
current devastation feels free to use
force perhaps even nuclear there is no
exception made for them if it so chooses
without any authorization by the
Security Council and even if there is no
armed attack or imminent attack and why
President Chirac as you remember
rejected war Mr Sarkozy who is now
trying to become press in the United
States of the France was recently
reported to have said that for him to
all options would be open in the case of
Iran as I say it as I see it this is a
way of saying goodbye to the
restrictions that were lay down with the
u.s. help in san francisco on the use of
force at least as regards actions to
stop the development of weapons of mass
destruction whether it goes beyond that
I don't know but at least in regard to
those whether the freedom the streamed
from the restriction that have been laid
down in the UN Charter in the interest
of world security are meant to apply for
all members of the UM or only to the
United States I don't know it could be
noted as an ominous sign however that
after the recent North Korean missile
firings essentially placed Japanese
politician mr. a B&D who is now expected
become Prime Minister said that
pre-emptive action pre-emptive actions
by Japan might become needed so it may
be contagious evidence them if it were
to become generally accepted the right
to take pre-emptive or preventive
strikes armed action without Security
Council authorization would be justified
against against anything that states
might rightly or wrongly perceive as a
growing threat this is another
expression that we used when can you use
a preemptive strike well when there is a
growing threat well that's a fairly
broad criteria and if that were to be
accepted brought in that would be heaven
and had the impact upon the world
security I think most governments will
see the this as a serious step back from
what was attained at San Francisco and
as a dangerous new license for big
states to change the political geography
a special problem with the use of armed
force that is taken preemptively or
preventively that's a say before an
armed attack
occurred or seen as imminent is that it
is inevitably must be taken on the basis
of intelligence suggesting the existence
of a threat you haven't seen the armed
attack say it's imminent so its
intelligence that tells you this and
after arc affair we know that this can
be a very shaky basis on which to start
the war armed actions against Iran or
Iranian nuclear installations today I
might add would not be a response to an
attack but only in response to a
possible Iranian aspirations to produce
nuclear weapons in the future I should
come back to the case of Iran I turn out
to the efforts to prevent the spread of
and secure the elimination or weapons of
mass destruction by peaceful means
efforts of this kind had deep roots in
the 19th century determine death and
successful efforts were made at The
Hague peace conferences to prohibit the
use of weapons that were particularly
cruel like the dum-dum bullet if you
remember that one was one that flattened
against the body and tore its way
through and some British er have
maintained that in India these were the
only things that will stop the savages
that were week meeting well they
prohibited the Sun dum-dum bullet and
they also soft and succeeded in
prohibiting Sun indiscriminate weapons
like poison and gas which would hit
civilians and military personnel
indiscriminately the threats from
weapons of terror to world security has
become immeasurably graver by the
appearance of nuclear weapons by the
possible use of ian even more biological
and chemical weapons and by the
emergence at the same time of non-state
actors terrorists who might not don't
have a territory against which you can
retaliate and who may not have the same
inhibitions as most states would have
now how successful has also unsuccessful
has the world being encountering these
types of weapons by cooperation and
agreements well first to some successes
with arrival of the nuclear weapons it
was concluded that agreements
prohibiting their use would not be
enough prohibiting use would not be
enough bands will have to extend to the
production and possession of the weapons
no weapons no use safest nuclear weapons
is the one you don't have
and this led to another conclusion
namely that on-site inspection would be
necessary a use of a weapon could be
visible would be visible like ass or
biological look but the production and
stocking a weapons might be done
secretly needless to say during the Cold
War you could not get any meaningful
agreements on such inspections in the
closest Oviatt Union nevertheless in
that period neither the u.s. nor the
Soviet Union thought biological weapons
were militarily useful and after an
initiative the President Nixon a
convention against the production and
stocking or biological weapons was
concluded without however any provisions
for continuous expections as in any case
the Russians would not have accepted
that during the Cold War the absence of
inspections under the be weapons treat
him reduced the treas effectiveness such
inspections might have made it difficult
for the Soviet Union to run the large be
weapons program which was revealed only
after the end of the Cold War and the
Iraqi regime of Saddam Hussein might
also had difficulty in engaging as he
did in the production and testing or by
be weapons without being detected by any
organization so the absence of
verification was a drawback in that
convention that early convention the
difficulty of establishing in devising
an inspection system sufficiently
effective to detect and deter violations
of the be Weapons Convention should not
be underestimated it's still there the
case of anthrax is hard if we have this
inspection both a nuclear we have it in
the in the chemical we don't have the
biological and it would be hard but
feasible and they have worked a lot on
on devising it the case in which anthrax
was sent by letters in the United States
in the year two thousand and two and
killed a number of people here has not
been cleared up yet despite the
significant inspection powers and other
powers which I assume that the FBI and
the CIA have so even in a country with
all the powers it's not so easy perhaps
to trace the sources of biological
weapons nevertheless if there had been
it might have worked as a deterrent
against the Russians to do it and
perhaps also against that I'm the same
those in the view of the weapons of mass
destruction Commission the rapid
development or biotechnology and the
large number of potential actors call
for agreement on a multi-faceted
international regime to give a some
confidence for first that weapons are
not made whether by States terrorists or
mad scientist secondly that any use of
be weapons is rapidly detected if it
were to inter alia through international
inspection and thirdly that National
Health Organization's a service
everywhere be ready to act promptly
against the discovery of any any
epidemic or any use of biological
weapons unfortunately the measures that
you need to counter say a plague or
smallpox they are the same whether it is
an attack it instigated by some
terrorists or if it happens naturally so
it's the same proportions that you need
to take a review conference later this
year of the be weapons convention offers
a new chance to approach these issues
regrettably a verification protocol that
had resulted from years of negotiations
was flatly rejected by the United States
at the latest review conference in 2001
and the outlook for the press this
year's conference review conference is
uncertain now the situation is much
better regarding chemical weapons a
conventional chemical weapons that had
taken some 20 years to negotiate was
completed and adopted at the end of the
Cold War in 1993 and it is in full
operation and you might have read in the
US newspapers about the actual
destruction of the huge supplies and
stocks of chemical weapons and the
difficult they have it's expensive to to
create who produced them but it's also
expensive to destroy them that
connection prohibits the production
storing and use of chemical weapons and
has an elaborate x in spection system
terrorism of course adds a new dimension
to the threat of chemical weapons and
called for stronger protection of
chemical industry and better control or
transport as well as exports nice to
have the newspapers today that there or
some resistance is discussing how this
shizz to be gone about and there were
discussions in Congress about it
revealing that the chemical industry was
not so keen to
have measures in place which would
protect their installations against
against sabotage and such such things
however it's clear that if terrorists
were to attack them a chemical industry
could be a very tempting target can be
perhaps even more dangerous if it is
destroy them if a nuclear power plant
work remember what happened in Bhopal in
India quite large numbers of of deaths
and of people who fell very ill for a
long time now there is no convention
prohibiting the production stocking and
you or use of nuclear weapons as there
is for the big weapons and the chemical
weapons such a contention would should
be a long-term aim we should aim for a
convention prohibiting outlawed a
nuclear weapons currently most
developers developments i think are go
in the opposite direction in an
important advisor opinion of the
International Court of Justice years ago
and court see is very limited scope for
it in illegal use of nuclear weapons
mainly in situations where the survival
of a state is at stake however even more
than in the cases of biological weapons
and chemical weapons confidence that
nuclear weapons will not be used will
only come from assurance that they do
not exist and as there are still some
27,000 nuclear weapons in eight or nine
countries and the possible development
or more or more weapons we cannot feel
that confidence today that they will not
be used so long as there are many
weapons around there's a threat the
approach of to reducing the threat of
nuclear weapons to world security has
been to limit testing to occur only
underground the partial test-ban treaty
and to prohibit nuclear weapons the the
deployment to nuclear weapons in certain
environments and areas thus their
presence was banned very early during
the Cold War in the Antarctic but when
the first big treaties in the cold war
between the US and the and well it was
multilateral was not on the US or Russia
and it's been prohibited to deploy new
caravans on the seabed and in outer
space their presence has also been
banned in a large number of nuclear
weapon-free zones and such zones now
cover
the actual in all the countries in the
southern hemisphere not there not the
Seas because the nuclear submarines go
everywhere including the southern
hemisphere but all the countries all the
land mass of the southern hemisphere are
covered by nuclear weapon-free zones the
treaty of non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons the NPT which entered into force
in 1970 may be said to aim at a nuclear
weapon free world it contains a basic
bargain under which the states parties
which do not have nuclear weapons
promise not to require them and the five
nuclear weapons States Parties China
France Russia the UK and the u.s.
promise to negotiate toward disarmament
today this fundamental treaty aiming to
rid the world of nuclear weapons is seen
as having a number of problems which
affect world security first three states
never adhered to it the India Israel and
Pakistan all three have nuclear weapons
and one state North Korea withdrew from
the treaty and declares that it has
documents secondly in some fear that the
NPT may be falling apart because of the
violations of the treaty by Iraq Libya
and North Korea before it withdrew and
furthermore there are suspicions about
Iranian intentions there are concerns
that the treaty is not a much help
against terrorists that may seek nuclear
weapons thirdly the non-nuclear weapon
States Parties the tritium note that
despite the reduction of the structure
nuclear weapons from the excessive
levels of the Cold War we are in a new
wave of rearmament they agreed in 1995
to extend their obligations under the
treaty without any further time
limitation and they obtained and in
return a number of commitments from the
nuclear weapon States Parties to
implement their disarmament obligations
seen in 1995 the treaty was up for
extension it was concluded for 25 years
and thereafter decision to extend it and
of course states could have said that no
we will extend it for five years or for
10 years but they actually went along
with what was the wish of the US and
many other states to extend it without
any further timely
so they actually committed themselves
for a fourth to the treaty without any
time limitation and in return for that
they say then you the nuclear weapons
days you must also do something and they
had a long number of demands which the
nuclear weapon states went along with
for instance through a comprehensive
test ban on ban on nuclear tests weapons
test and the conclusion of convention
comprising a verified prohibition of the
production of enriched uranium and
plutonium for weapons these were two of
the conditions that they saw accepted by
a nuclear weapon States and more than 10
years later neither of these promised
has materialized and many nuclear
weapons state non-nuclear weapon States
now feel cheated under the treaty so
they see in erosion of the treaty on on
there perfected achieved or done by the
nuclear weapon States new nuclear
weapons are being designed and the
latest military doctrines doctrines give
them a wider role in the u.s. there is a
lively discussion about developing new
types of nuclear warheads and in the UK
the government may soon decide on a new
nuclear program stretching far into this
century and in Russia and in China they
consider measures to ensure capability
on that part to penetrate the missile
shield that the US is building and
saying it's for rogue states but which
both the Russians in the Chinese fear
that it may be aimed one day to enable
us to attack them by retaining immunity
for itself the Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty which was adopted in 1996 has
remained in limbo after it was rejected
by the US Senate nuclear halves are
deepening their addiction while ever
more loudly warning the norm haves
against nuclear weapons the world's main
instrument for negotiations about arms
control and disarmament the Geneva
Conference has not been able to agree on
a work program for over 10 years so
these are criticisms and grievances that
the non-nuclear weapon States advances
say that the treaty is being undermined
by these things against this catalogue
of problems we must also register some
successes for the treatment first a
large number of states which could have
developed nuclear weapon
and still could do so have joined the
treaty as non-nuclear weapon States that
say committing themselves not acquire
nuclear weapons among them are three
that demonstrate that power great power
status is not dependent upon weapon
nuclear weapons I'm thinking of Germany
and Japan and Brazil Mexico to say
economics the lists large GDP in brazil
i think at the present time secondly
when separating from the Soviet Union
Ukraine and Kazakhstan and bl Russian
seeded handed over their nuclear weapons
to Russia and received security
assurances and joined non-proliferation
treaty as non-nuclear with mistake so
that was not a foregone conclusion that
it would happen but it did happen and
thirdly south africa became the first
state to roll back from a nuclear weapon
status and join the NPT now the nuclear
program nuclear programs in North Korea
and Iran have undoubtedly relevance for
the world security today and I returned
to them though and comment upon
especially upon them the program for
enrichment of uranium in Iran and the
production of plutonium and possible
enrichment of uranium in North Korea
takes place intense areas and constitute
acute political problems which need
early solution in both cases there are
fears that the production of enriched
uranium and plutonium a lead and in the
case of DPRK has led to production of
nuclear weapons that may be used the
concerns are acute first of all in the
neighborhood of these countries South
Korea and Japan and Israel and the
Middle East linked to these concerns are
fears about possible Domino effects if
they were to go ahead with no
commitments the aversion to nuclear
weapons is deep-rooted in Japan and I
think it would take much to provoke
Japan to move to these weapons but if in
spite of all that were to happen
tensions with China tensions with China
would dramatically increase the efforts
of the US and other states taking part
in the six-party talks in Beijing have
wisely aimed at removing the incentives
for the DPRK to develop and possess
nuclear weapons an agreement on
principle was reached
in visits that the whole DPRK nuclear
program would be eliminated and strict
verification introduced the North and
the South would confirm an agreement a
deal nuclearization of a game into 99 22
that neither will have enrichment nor
reprocessing plants South Korea doesn't
have either of them but North Korea has
had a hot and still has a reprocessing
plant which I visited myself and and
they claim or it's believed that they
also have enrichment that they thought
the technology from mr. Khan just as the
Iranians did the government of the North
is further told that it may receive
issue assurance that it will not be the
subject to attacks from the outside auto
foreign subversion if it abandons and it
is scraps its nuclear program all of the
nuclear program it is also told that the
isolation in which it has found itself
would be ended and that diplomatic
relations could be opened with the
United States and Japan to bring them
back out from the coal if provided of
course that they scrapped the nuclear
program so I think this is a way a wise
approach that we have taken to do away
with the incentives that they have had
to go for nuclear weapons assure them
about security and assure them that if
they were to scrap this program they
would be would be accepted in the
international community they might have
to commit themselves to more than just
doing away with their nuclear program
because North Korea is a country that
has violated many many rules of
international law and at the present
time as you may know they are earn us
has taken from the economic restrictions
we have to busier than I on the ground
on the alleged allegation at any rate
that they have been involved in
counterfeiting operations about dollars
in the case of Iran the risk of domino
effect seems a little less clear the
Arab states would worry about a
nuclear-armed non-arab non-arab Iran and
so would perhaps dirty but unlike Japan
these days would have a rather long way
to go to nuclear capability Japan having
huge stocks of plutonium and able and
reaching uranium they could make nuclear
weapons in no time at all whereas in the
Middle East turkey they are far away
from it differently from the DPRK Iran
has declared that it only seeks the
capacity
to enrich uranium to supply power
reactors with fuel the ia and the
intelligence agencies around the world
has been hard at work to examine the
Iranian contention and while the IAEA
has not yet returned rate concluded that
the aim of the Iranian program is to
make a weapon others declare this
conclusion with as much conviction as
they showed about the nuclear weapons
program in Iraq in 2002 and 2003 but
it's clear that Iran also has come much
further in nuclear field then then Iraq
had in 2003 and that the country is not
destroyed the start they are at a
different level a number of
circumstances are invoked to show that
an intention behind the Iranian program
for the enrichment uranium is to make
weapons for instance that the program
was kept secret for many many years in
violation of Iran's safeguards
obligations to the IAEA and that a
research reactor is being constructed a
40 megawatt heavy water reactor that is
an excellent producer or plutonium it
would require a reprocessing plant to to
make the plutonium but the research
reactor is certainly one that would fit
into the plutonium production program
and third year that the design for
nuclear weapon was obtained from the
Pakistani scientist mr. Khan not only
centrifuges which they imported from
Pakistan but also designed for weapon
has been handed over I shall go into
these and other arguments and
counter-arguments about the Iranian
intentions very like Ian there has not
been a consistency in the Iranian
program when Ames during the 20 years
that the country has traveled before it
reached an ability to enrich grams or
milligram quantities of uranium to some
3.5 or five percent it has been shown
that the roots of the program go back to
the 1980 sometime that was the time when
the Iraq actually was working hard to
move to towards nuclear witness but the
iraqis by 2000 and by 1991 had come
pretty close to enrichment they had they
switched from an old fashioned method
them to centrifuges and if Iran started
in the 1980s as the year
his did then and only now in 2006 has
reached the capacity to enrich milligram
quantities to her grand quantities to
three-point-five percent they must have
worked pretty slowly off and on very
likely there is also not a United or
Iranian government behind the Richmond
program but one in which various
factions have different at various
attitudes I cannot help but feeling that
it is not very meaningful at this point
to search for Iran's real intention
certainly would be damaging to them if I
were able to prove that there is intense
but otherwise I can't see it's very
meaningful after all even if their
intentions were purely peaceful today
this could change in the future in the
few years time they could change their
view so I don't see that it would change
the attitude very much to Iran if we
today concluded that it was peaceful
which is not done what is certain is
that Iran and then in any other country
would be a couple of years closer to a
weapons option if it were to have an
industrial capability of enriching
uranium and it's of interest to note
that while the concern about the Iraq
Iran is intense it is part of the more
general concern in the world about the
possibility that more countries about
which there are no particular suspicions
and which are not located in sensitive
areas may seek enrichment capability and
thereby be years closer to weapons
option what is very meaningful indeed in
spin Sybilla naive at the present moment
is to consider what factors if any could
persuade Iran to suspend at least for
prolonged period of time it's programmed
for enrichment it seems to me that the
European states while they seek to
convince Iran that it does not need a
capability to enrich uranium have wisely
thought to demonstrate that they fully
understand and endorse Iran's ambition
to move into high technology generally
including nuclear the area Clarence's
ready to assist Iran in this ambition by
facilitating investments offering
advantages in the field of trade and
finance including support for Iran's
entry into the World Trade Organization
and they also are ready to transfer
nuclear technology directly nuclear even
for peaceful uses and assure Iran of the
supply of nuclear fuel there by
acknowledging the legitimacy of an
Iranian program for the peaceful use of
nuclear energy which is important
because if there was a quest no status
request no developing country moving
into the high technology age including
nuclear question of pride they are are
affirming that this is legitimate what I
am missing in this negotiation are two
elements that only the US could
contribute and that were put on the
table in the case of North Korea firstly
and assurances about about security
merely holding out a promise about a
dialogue on security in the future is
not enough in a country that maybe be
seeing threats against them might
perhaps be more likely to run for the
nuclear weapons than one that is assured
that they will not be attacked in the
future if they stay without nuclear
weapons and the other the which was also
given the case of North Korea would be
about official not warm close relations
but official relations diplomat
sometimes people see diplomatic
relations sort of gesture of friendship
no it's not it's a question of
communicating having a channel of talk
and of course many of the European
countries have diplomatic relations with
Iran but the US after the trauma of the
embassy occupation during the revolution
has not had any in such relations one
may assume that the Iranian government
is concerned about the huge US military
presence in Iraq in Pakistan Afghanistan
and elsewhere in the region and that the
Uranus also remembers the u.s. actions
that toppled the democratically elected
mr. Mossadegh in 1953 nevertheless it
may not unreasonably conclude that the
US and Israel would be there reluctant
after Iraq and after Lebanon to use
military force and that on balance it
could be safer for Iran Iran from be
safer from armed attacks and subversion
if it's suspended in Richmond then if it
moved on with the program it's such a
conclusion would be more like shame if
security assurance were part of the
package offered to Iran in return for
the desired suspension of enrichment
I'm not aware however that had been any
hint from the negotiating states about
their readiness to make an offer about
the about security of assurances further
the Iranian government may well feel
that it was treated unjustly and by the
industrialized world when Iran was the
victim of Saddam Hussein's aggression in
the 1980s and it has been unfairly
ostracized the US has offered to
participate in discussions with Iran
provided at the country first suspend
first to spend its enrichment program
and this may be may look as magnanimous
in may not be looked at as a magnanimous
in Tehran as it does in Washington where
I probably took some political fighting
before offering the u.s. to participate
that US would participate in talks in
the case of North Korea the u.s. does
not ask for any payment to sit down to a
talk but seems ready to offer normal
official relations as a part of a
negotiated settlement a similar offer to
sit down for talk might be a valuable
chipped in the game with Iraq three last
point first the Security Council of
negotiating powers have demanded that
Iran should suspend its enrichment
program prior to any detailed talks
about what they might be given in return
security council resolution states that
that they should suspend the Richmond
program before third first of August and
if they didn't do that there's a threat
of sanctions but if they do suspend then
there can be talks about about quid pro
quos now this demand of Iran to stop
their program in advance may look like a
technical negotiate and matter but can
we be surprised that this suggestion has
been constantly consists consistently
rejected which player in a game is
willing to give the other side is trump
card before is it down to play perhaps a
time limit suspension starting at the
same time as the talks would offer a way
out of this dilemma which I think has
been self inflicted by the negotiating
states on the western side second
question is what is the reason for the
hate
in the case of Iran I do not exclude the
possibility that the Iranian side wants
to drag its feet and meanwhile to seek
to increase its leverage by building
another cascade of centrifuges just as
North Korea may increase its leverage by
reprocessing more plutonium as they are
reporting mr. Sayle Harrison reported
from the visit North Korea the other day
that the North Koreans were planning to
take out more rods from the research
reactors and sent them to reprocessing
there by saying that well this is what
we do so long as you don't negotiate
with us and the Iranians may also
conceivably drag their feet in order to
build put in more cascades to increase
the willingness of negotiation of the
other side nevertheless we are told that
it would be several years before Iran
could enrich enough material to make
bombs there is thus in my assessment
time for talks waiving the sanctions
court might not facilitate negotiations
it is by no means axiomatic that carrots
must be coupled by the waving of sticks
the latter may simply look humiliating
and provoke a national wish in Iran to
stand tall third and last limb there is
a crying need for a revival of global
disarmament efforts and a further
development of respect for the UN for
the United Nations and I saw in the
newspaper this morning that overwhelming
majority of Americans feel that either
the you the UM should shape up or else
it should be shipped out so it may be
not be a popular message to come with
but nevertheless that's mine there might
be a better chance to dissuade others
including North Korea and Iran from
developing nuclear weapons if the
nuclear weapons States began themselves
to move away from these weapons and
thereby strength and world security and
use of the UM
X has offered to answer a good number of
questions and you can see that there are
some microphones on the side and so who
wants to start you will start do you
think that pre-emptive strikes against
nuclear biological or chemical weapons
facilities are justified under any
circumstances and if so what
circumstances would those be well I
don't think they are justified in any
circumstances concerning biological
weapons or chemical weapons this has
been a widening of the how the doctrine
in the US and not only the US but also
in other country china i think is the
only country at the present time who
says that they are categorically against
any any user first strike now when it
comes to a nuclear weapons I don't think
that pre-emptive strikes are justified I
mean I go by the UN Charter and that
charter will as we said develop allow a
a strike in in retaliation in return for
Anna charm your tank now that's cheap no
one disputes that but one has gone a
little further and saying that also in
the situations where the attack is
imminent now that goes back to a case
from the 90s n2a Caroline case which is
famous in international law but imminent
even imminent of course work is may be
difficult to define what it's meant and
it's reasonable to say that if you can
see that there are missiles on their way
or if there are fleet come close to your
Shores then you don't have to wait is it
confusing
something about so I can well understand
the discussion that is imminent to a
narrow criteria the high-level
commission that advice Kofi Annan did
not think I should walk away from him I
produces means rather that when you hear
if you hear it criticized in the u.s.
strategies what is the electorate what
are the clergy and they offer and what i
hear is simply a growing threat our
current strategy isn't just total
freedom and if that is accepted by the
US well presumably applied to others so
I could I could envisage an honest
discussion about where the border
doesn't goes but I don't think that you
know I think they're throwing out the
criteria their work and that and without
putting any other in the face I say I'll
put it closer I swallow it rightly
mentioned that in the history of the NPT
the fact that the haves also not kept
their end of the bargain had weakened
the incentives for those who are signed
to keep on maintaining their adherence
to the NPT and the outsiders join in if
they had not joined in earlier now in
that context suppose Britain for example
word to say today that we will renounce
nuclear weapons whatever we have like
Kazakhstan did we will give all our
nuclear weapons to the United States and
we accept the an example by renouncing
nuclear weapons all together that might
be a good signal see this npt doesn't
make the notion that you clear weapons
are not legitimate weapons to use it is
not discipline restricting
that itself add an issue not a right
objective so what would something like
this an example of an existing have
renouncing it and would go a long way in
convincing others were contemplating not
to loose doing English well the Indian
position is that they are not going to
abandon nuclear weapons except in the
context of others moving towards nuclear
disarmament frankly with the UK there is
an active discussion at the present time
it seems that both Blair and brown and
the certain of the Conservatives will
our intent to go on prolonging the
program far into the communitary I asked
myself whether how necessary is this
they have promised this ramen do they
need nuclear weapons more than Spain or
Italy and why what would happen I mean
they might say the French will never
give it up so I why should we do it but
I think they were making greater mark in
the history of mankind if they decide to
know we let it be let it peter out then
if they prolong it but i think they will
their minister defense came out and
defended it and said you know y'all but
you know the future is uncertain well
well very wise words
but I don't think is much of an argument
so no I don't think it's going to happen
but I think it would be a great sing it
with them it would turn and what we need
at the present time is the turning of
the tide somewhere and I don't therefore
hope to for this one but they cut the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty is about
the most urgent there are a number of
others but but that's the most urgent
yes um dr. Blake's thank you for coming
today I'm but I I'm sorry if I bungle
the policy my breeding lately has been
towards directed studies and not towards
the news but um I would wonder how you
would analyze the present policy the
united states is considering regarding
Indian nuclear weapons in trading
specifically uranium or the ability to
create weapons grade uranium for a
closer diplomatic tie with the country
do you think that that's a fair trade or
that that would rather endanger the
world to adding one more nuclear power
well we are written about a little
analysis of the india-us deal here which
i think is rather fair even-handed you
can look at that deal from different
perspectives and we look at it only from
the viewpoint to non-proliferation but
you can also look at from the viewpoint
of an energy energy provision of the
world are you many of you will not agree
with me but I am a strong advocate of
use of civilian nuclear power for
electricity I my friends will say well
let's have wind power and solar power
you're not going to have electricity of
Shanghai oh calcutta satisfied by wind
power
so I'm in favor of it and also in favor
very much so strangely I spent 60 years
at the ia helping to strengthen the
safety in the operations and safety and
taking care of the waist incident now
India and in China China is building
nuclear power very fast and they are
important nuclear power plants from
Canada from Russia and from France not
yet from the US but i'm sure the newest
nucleons would direct to see to sell
nuclear reactors also so the chinese are
moving very fast network I think it's
fine I should help them on the security
side that's fine I can see that India
two billion people that is desirable
that they have access to the latest
technology that they be able to import
this nuclear technology so they're from
the point of view of energy which we do
not discuss with we probably have
different views about that in the
Commission I think it is desirable that
the import can occur however we write
and I and I wholeheartedly agree that
from the viewpoint of proliferation it
has some problems as it looks at the
present time because it would enable
India to import nuclear fuel and if they
do and if they then use their own
uranium for a richmond in richmond they
can make it also for high enrichment for
that bombs the enrichment plants are not
going to be under under international
control so that could facilitate for
them to make more nuclear weapons now
there would be a remedy to this and that
would be the fmcg the fissile material
cutoff now that is the treaty I
mentioned a few of your mother what I've
heard about which says that I should be
a commitment treaty against the
production or more enriched uranium or
more plutonium for weapons purposes and
it was been on the books for a long time
a u.s. actually put forward a draft to
it in Geneva I recently but without any
verification has been on the books for a
long time because none of the nuclear
weapons States need any more plutonium
or or in return they have so much
already that they had the problems to do
away and to consume it now but this
treaty would have also verification and
if that treaty were entered into with
verification then India Pakistan China
Brazil
and South Africa and well any country
that had had enrichment Japan well they
already had verification they would all
be party to it and then Pakistan and
China I could be sure that India would
not use its enrichment plants to make
weapons-grade to talk in uranium or blue
so if the US were to move and add
verification to the draft they submit in
Geneva then I think a lot would be would
be a lot less concerned about the India
agreement with India similarly if they
agree with India that they that India
should commit themselves against any
further in nuclear tests well India
Pakistan did to the end of the 90s issue
as you remember but in India should also
commit themselves against that that
would be helpful but the US constrained
to do that because they have themselves
rejected yeah the nuclear test from the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty dr.
Blake's I'm curious to know apart from
going actively into politics or reading
your book okay what if anything can the
ordinary citizen do to help free the
world of weapons of mass destruction
well I heard my friend John Lee asana
was they had President General Assembly
and was resign left that now he said in
a speech at the UN that the spoke to
NGOs that it takes both passion and
compassion fine I think you adds one
more that is knowledge but it's fine to
argue out of passion good feeling we
respect that but if you want to achieve
something well you need also to add
knowledge I remember well was a young
legal assistant to Alabama Bureau dolly
in the 1960s I was in Geneva for
disarmament and she had another impact
and much of it was not a passionate
compassionate was that she relied on and
engaged a lot of research workers from
Swedish military research so when we
talked about seismic events and so forth
we knew we could actually debate with
the great part well not always that
debate helps and irrational
argument helps but of course it's one
element also public opinion is in his
important factor in democratic countries
at any rate they mail it they may listen
to it I wouldn't say that the u.s.
government was opportunistic in the case
of the Iraqi I don't think they listened
to the masses at least we're
demonstrating on Third Avenue else or I
lived at the time but still in a
democratic states i think it does have a
certain impact so i would say that yes
try to search for the truth which is
very difficult i mean i've been here as
then listen to some television and I
think it's frightful one-sided point of
view I think even sometimes New York
Times were held Tribune which I read is
a little on the right side and then I
just cover you over here people think
it's very left-wing but but it is hard I
mean you you have but there lots of
blogs around I often read something
called Asia online which has a different
view and where you get other insights
into what's happening and we need that
because there is a tendency in the media
to run with the government we remember
before the Iraq war how how they were
all running in that director this is a
pariah and it's clear that they are
guilty it was like the Inquisition you
know they're guilty just fine black cat
is walking over that's evidence and the
New York Times in Washington Post rarity
is decent off towards to come out and
say that we have examined what happened
we found that those who said that yes
they are guilty they have it they were
on the first page and the reservations
the questions they were on page 18 well
it's the same works the same way in
Europe the media run with someone until
until they find that no it's more or
who's worthy would get more readers if
they go in the other direction then then
they may turn around so I think as Tim
our citizens negraph Democratic says we
need to try to start it to seek the
truth and also to make our views known
to our people you may join organizations
of course I mean I as a young man I'm
not terribly embedded within a party but
I joined a liberal part in Sweden long
ago because I felt I had greater
influence in politics if I could
influence through a party and I think
one can in many places at any rate I
can't give you a generous recipe apron
good luck
towards the end of your talk you talked
about how the UN needs to shape up or
ship out and I was wondering what sorts
of reforms do you suggest the UN
undertake to address more modern
problems of terrorism where you have
people who are attacking the United
States but don't identify with a
particular country or spore state well
I'm somewhat appalled that Europe on the
whole I think we we do not have it all
his view that you can see developed here
I cut out from The Herald Tribune 13 a
year ago 13 September 2005 an article by
Newt Gingrich so limited the United
Nations is best for America well that's
what is preferred by the opinion polls
today I think that maybe the US has not
come to quite to terms with being the
lone superpower and how to make use of
the UN they see the awareness possibly
someone that can vote with them in the
Security Council that's fine but if it
doesn't do as the US then is irrelevant
that's what was said before the Iraq war
and somehow there is a resentment
against the security cams Security
Council in the UN for not supporting the
war against Iran and yet it seems to me
that if the security house that had
voted for this intervention and said
okay we authorize the world what would
we assault of this council today to
authorize it on the basis of faith-based
intelligence or fake fake based
intelligence
so I think the security was wise they
they did not say that they excluded an
armed intervention at any stage they
simply said they wanted to have more
inspections and as I said at the time
when the attack took place where there
he had carried out 700 inspections at
500 different sites and about three
dozens of sites which had been given to
us by you as and other intelligence and
we told them that look we had been to
the size you have suggested and there
was no weapon semester in some cases
found conventional weapons or other
things but no weapons of mass
destruction I think my theory is that if
we had gone along with continuing
inspections for a few months more then
we would have been able to say it in
Italian is that all the sites that you
have suggested did not have any weapons
of mass destruction and they should they
ought to have generate I've told their
executive branches that no we begin to
doubt it see eye to eye was asked in the
autumn of 2002 what are your gut
feelings about weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq and I said I am NOT
here to tell anybody but my gut feelings
I am here to inspect but my gut feelings
were suspicious because I'd seen how
they played cat-and-mouse with
inspectors in in the whole 90s so my gut
feelings were very skeptical about them
but preferably as we went along with
more and more inspections we became more
and more doubtful and the area that of
course was the most sensitive was the
nuclear and already in the autumn of
2002 I remember David Albright in
Washington came out as expressed grave
doubts about the aluminum tubes so did
the IAEA and we heard about the contract
on on the importer yellowcake from New
share and I don't know nuclear was not
my desk but I said why should Iran
import yellowcake it's a very very long
way from a nuclear bomb and now there's
an enormous discussion about Valerie
plume and mr. Wilson etc but people do
not record and recall that my colleague
ElBaradei sat in the Security Council
before the war and he came out and said
we have now got we've got a copy of the
contract and
we have concluded that it is not
authentic now that's diplomatic lingo
for fake and if you had said the fake
maybe if someone would have noticed it
but it was not authentic it took the ia
less than a day to see that this
contract was a forgery so I think that's
relevant that was before the war but
every Wilson deal later on was I think
to suggest that there was knowledge
within the administration okay but the
u.s. governed the whole world had been
told by the ia that the contract was a
forgery and no one contradicted that so
these these things have come before
before the invasion and they are feeling
then about the evidence was feeling that
that it went down the credibility of the
evidence port the evidence pointed more
to an absence of weapons that we express
doubts I expressed doubts about some
things that Colin Powell is a very very
courteous time terms but they torment to
pieces for saying that now so our
feeling we're going down at the same
time the determination and that curve
that went up and and that's where where
we were it's a tragedy and I but one
lesson that I think we should draw from
it is that professional international
inspection is a desirable thing not
cosmetic cosmetic inspection could be
worse than none because that may love
you into a false sense of security that
professional inspection that's what we
did and no one has criticized the
quality of the inspections that one
should look at that and the governments
have the two streams and information
they have the information from their
intelligence and they have it from from
the inspectors if they coincide well
then there's corroboration and that's
fine but if they collide well then they
ought to say well hey there is something
wrong somewhere here and and and perhaps
correct the course and yet I find that
even after the the war there is a sort
of allergy against international
inspection not in the ia they want to
have more inspection Iran and a few
other places but in as I mentioned this
treat against prohibiting the production
of a rich uranium and plutonium for
weapons the US has placed on table of
proposal that contains
nothing about inspection and I think
that's a mistake I think that maybe is
founded in some feeling that we are so
big and we are good and everybody must
believe is that we cannot have
inspection but you cannot ask the rest
of the world to go for except inspection
unless you yourself do it i'm sure i
might have veered away from what you
asked originally did i answer some yeah
I was um it was good but I was more
considering the fact that um the UN
deals with relations between states and
terrorists don't affiliate with states
well I get back to the uni and Gingrich
see I think that I mean the UN of course
is an organization that has many defects
it originally was about 50 states and
now was 190 states and there is a
democratic deficit in the General
Assembly and there is another Democratic
deficit in the Security Council in the
General Assembly every mini state has a
vote and a seat and it's useful for the
world to have a village council which
various voices are heard but of course
you have the Kurds who exist they are
more numerous than the Palestinians or
maybe there are more numerous than the
Israelis i'm not sure but they are not
hurt so the General Assembly is more
like a forum in which new ideas can be
injected they've done a great little
things in human rights started there the
law of the sea started their environment
started their discussion about terrorism
started there so as the discussion forum
is it is has fulfilled the great gate
service but it's not very operative and
it's very heavy etc so there are
shortcomings of this Security Council
was composed of those who have the power
in 1945 and that's not the group today
and you see then that Germany Japan and
Brazil are clamoring to get seats in the
Security Council well why do they want
seats when is it in order to help the
world and the Security Council to pursue
a policy of peace for the world or is it
to pursue their own foreign policy but I
think you've judged by those who sit
there and all on the permanent seats
they pursue their own foreign policies
and it's not really for the world and
yet under the chart
we have delegated the road states have
delegated to the Security Council to
take decisions which are binding upon
the rest of us and which we have to
implement so they they are as it were
appointed to do then they should act
also i think in respir the
responsibility responsibility to the
rest of the world and there's been a
good deal of dissatisfaction in the
General Assembly that the council
especially the special the permanent
members are so what are they they take
control and there is not enough of of
feedback and and sensing or what the
assembly what the majority you know that
you're in the Cold War II they had the
so-called actress on plan adopted under
which if they're the security count the
General Assembly could take up the case
of an attack an armed attack if the
Security Council had been blocked by a
veto well that was a way of getting the
world public opinion world opinion
working now if you had had oh the or the
inverse happening in the case in Iraq if
someone had moved over the rocky issue
to the General Assembly you would have
had a vast majority against the war so
the Security Council is also an
institution which might stand
improvement I'm not saying that the UN
is an organization that does not stand
improve but I don't think that the
biggest problems or corruption or heavy
management I mean I lived with the UN
since 1950 corruption is not very common
you find cases where people cheat with
travel travel claims and so that's done
all the big organization this is pity
and I know one defensive and it should
be prosecuted okay but if you look at
the oil-for-food which has been the
tremendous thing here in this country I
think it has been in Maine being
exploited to describe the UN as corrupt
they found the Volcker Commission's are
gone deep into it and everyone's
interested you have thousands of cases
to pursue and they find very little
corruption there they've expressed some
suspicions against mr. Pennell seven and
that's a money coming to him he said
from an inheritance from an aunt I don't
know but anyway there was not much you
found some cases of corruption in
procurement in the UN which was not
linked to the to the oil-for-food but
the big thing was between
Iraq and those to whom is sold oil and
those from whom it bought food you see
all four food was instituted at the time
when Saddam didn't want to have it he
had very harsh sanctions that really
sank around if he didn't didn't want to
accept them but the UN couldn't stand
seeing all the suffering of the rocket
and said that we will allow you to
censor some seltzer and so much oil and
eventually they were loud sell any
qantas they want to and but you will
have to then abstain from using the
money to get any weapons and we will
examine what you will buy and so I'm
said okay eventually he accepted that
however he said I must be allowed to
decide to whom do I sell the oil from
whom do i buy the food and the UN said
Security Council not the secondary honor
the UN Security Council that said behind
said yes okay you'll do that now in that
construction was the beginning the
possibility for corruption because
Saddam went out and his people
throughout and said to oil importers in
the world that you may buy our oil but
remember ten percent or he went around
the world say i want to buy wheat and
from you i buy it from you about ten
percent now this was how i think even
billions actually were paid into a
society in huge quantities amounts of
money that was the big corruption and i
think it that the oil-for-food people
would have needed to be an FBI to see
through these contracts they did war
that were warning source of the security
guard but the Security Council that was
responsible did not react very much
except that they did change the
calculation of the price for oil rather
late in the game so they were aware but
all this has been used to show that the
UN is corrupt it is not by a larger
corrupt organization it's heavy to
manage because if you have 190
nationalities yeah it's it's a bit heavy
it also has its charm its attraction to
be in a multinational context and I
lived with that but sometimes I think of
the UN as a sort of orchestra in which
you have many instruments and many
players and of course if some instrument
is broken well then you can fix it but
if the players
participants do not want to use the same
tune or if the first violinist does not
want to participate then is hard to get
a nice tune out of its well I think with
that we